the ukrainian countryside turns into
what
my now uh
past colleague who died several years
ago robert conquest called a vast belson
and by that you know the images of
bodies just lying everywhere
you know people dead
and uh
and dying
you know of hunger which is
by the way i mean
as you know i've spent a lot of time
studying genocide i don't think there's
anything worse than dying of hunger from
what i have read i mean you see terrible
ways that people die right
but dying of hunger is just such a
horrible horrible thing and so for
example
we know there were many cases of
cannibalism in the countryside because
there wasn't anything to eat people were
eating their own kids
you